okay welcome to pointed questions live I
thank you for coming out and being
witness to to this is the first time
we've ever done a live version of this
podcast but I think it's the first time
anyone's ever done a live podcast have
any podcast that's right
this is the first lives life the first
like this is actually like the first
live show of all time right this is
number one first live show so this is a
milestone and not just podcasting but in
life the milestone in life it's a life
milestone but but anyway so okay well
look by the way we'll assume that I've
already recorded the intro I know it's
weird that this is like live streaming
too but I already did an intro and
explain what's going on you're already
established is here your new tablet
person and so I guess we'll just get
right into it with our guest
so James well should do a quick
establishment about what people hear
yeah okay yeah right you're right okay
so for the people who are here our guest
today is is an English teacher in high
school high school English teacher his
name is James and we're just gonna ask
him questions about his his job and his
experience with that job yeah and my
name is Brent Weinbach my name is Andrew
Michelle was an Gemma Sean and this is
James hey Brett Andrew actually give him
a round of applause well pause for
jeaious
thanks guys lose a lot so how long have
you been teaching for let's see so I
guess my seventh year teaching and is it
have you've always been at the same
school
I know spread around so like technically
I'm a middle school right now but oh
you're the middle school it's kind of
like they blend into each other okay so
it's and then I was a full out high
school before that it's eight through
twelve yeah uh-huh and before that you
were where high school I like a junior
senior how do you like the mix do you
like do are your students a range of
Ages as well thatthat span that
yeah something at grade so oh it covers
just those two oh okay you only do
seventh eighth grade yeah oh so I'm
sorry it goes through seven through 12
maybe yeah yeah absolutely
okay Oh is everything all right there
okay should we redo anything no okay so
I'm sorry
so it's 7 through 12 and you only do 7th
and 8th right now what you used to do
high school yeah and I've previously
taught just straight high school uh-huh
and so what's your favorite grade um
probably the great I'm in now which is 7
7 eighth grade yeah what do you like
even more so it's right probably not
eighth but how come you know I think
that like brain starts sort of like
changing around eighth grade yeah for
the worse for the worst absolutely yeah
it doesn't really get better so does it
just get worse all the way up until 12th
grade uh yeah I would say so it's just
like different degrees of worse and like
in different directions for the most
part so so do you mean they their brains
become more manly in at 8:00 yeah and
8th grade that is yes super manly but
they're not but they're more childlike
in seventh grade and you like that more
maybe there's more innocent at least
yeah they're more they're more innocent
like their priorities change
they're their priorities definitely
change when they hear it good ok so what
are some of the things they value in
eighth grade as opposed to seventh grade
nicely just like like [ __ ] mostly you
know I mean they don't actually like
achieve any of that but it's just
constantly on the brain what is your
what do you do you find it easier to
discipline seventh graders over eighth
oh yeah cuz like when you're in seventh
grade you know they come in they still
view you with like some kind of
authority and you can still do the like
the mental jujitsu around them you know
they're just not smart enough honestly
it's what boils down to oh and so you
like that they're not as developed yeah
because you know you just have this
added advantage in that you can like you
know maneuver around complicated
situations a lot more easily otherwise
and did you do but what about the high
schoolers the nine through twelve how
the challenge you on things right you
know so they're more challenging more
than eight so they just get more and
more challenging they do but like we met
ordered a mellow out a service like a
junior senior because it's like
previously taught junior senior and they
definitely like calm down at a certain
point in time and like when they reached
that point in time they just kind of
want to get out and so let just do what
they need to do to get out have you seen
did you ever have a student who was a
ninth grader and saw them grow into a
twelfth grader no cuz I switch schools
yeah yeah I mean I know I have some like
students who are you know in college and
that sort of thing now but it's you keep
in touch watch students go through yeah
they'll come back and visit things like
that so you're friendly with some of the
students yeah there's no taboo of
becoming friends with students or not
afterwards yeah is it is it is there
taboo at school of teachers becoming
friends with students while there's
still there student yeah because I mean
you want to keep that like boundary
right at all points to some teachers not
to keep that boundary I mean like it's
great for some people I would say but I
mean you tried to with us apart you know
some kids don't really like understand
that though so I remember one kid said
that we were friends he was going around
saying like hey we're friends right and
about you yeah and I said like no we're
not friends I'm your teacher and like
that really pissed him off and I was
like the last time you talked to me so
well you know it's like how old what's
grade was here he was junior why did he
think you guys were friends I think he
just thought that we were friendly cuz
I'm not really like a particularly
strict guy or anything like those things
where do you think he but did you act
any differently towards him than you did
to any other
no did he what did he have a lot of
friends no you were kind of number one
for yes he was the hole you were he you
were his only friend
yeah so when you told them how did you
do that how did you tell him let's say
Andrews the he's the student okay and I
just want to let you know I love that
we're friends yeah you know we're not
friends but no but we talk and you're
nice to me instead yeah but we're not
friends I'm your teacher you can't be
friends with the teacher man but Chris
okay hold on a second so but what so did
he cry it all when he told him that no
he said I see I was like oh I see I see
how it is man wow it was like the nod
and the shake weight was down nod slight
slight slight side to side shake and
then it was just silence what kind of
style did he have uh he had a big beanie
and a shirt like a corn shirt cling he
was a corn type yeah he was one of those
guys so he was a beanie corn he was a
children of the corn
his children the corn but I mean this
was like what in 2010 so I mean like he
was it was way off it was late he was
late so do you still have was he still a
student of yours just for a short period
of time this is like tortilla anyway so
he was a senior he was eight so he was a
11th grader yeah and then I just didn't
have him and what was his full name so I
you had heard that he was going around
telling people that you were guys were
friends yeah and he brought it up to me
just sort of like passingly and you know
lo he said hey I think it's cool mr.
James how we're we're friends yeah we're
friends man we're homey and I like that
I like that about a relationship that's
what he said you didn't go say I like
that about our relationship you know you
know in so many words and the corn kind
of style like a corner where syllables
more loud and kangri yeah so did you and
then so when you said hey like I mean
okay did you do it just like you did it
to Andrew or were you a little more a
little like nicer about it or was a lot
nicer so what do you I mean huh
I mean I'm like revising this in my mind
this and my mind I was very
very very likes fatherly and Stern but
it was probably kind of like timid and
gradually and and did it seem like he
was gonna cry or anything I didn't see
any tears hmm
was that hard for you to do uh it was
uncomfortable yeah yeah it was
uncomfortable Wow yeah I'm glad that
we're starting on this really really no
so do you do like to do you do you feel
like you are an influence on the
students I mean obviously you're
influencing them as far as their
education goes but do you think of
yourself as a role model no I'm not a
role model you don't think any of the
students look up to you in any way they
might in some regard but I wouldn't
regard myself as a role model has anyone
ever said so that mr. James could I want
to be like you know no one's ever said
that to me
uh-huh but I'm looking forward to that
happening someday do you like the idea
of inspiring stevia Slee that's probably
I mean do you that's it
I mean not to make it sound corny or
anything but do you do you like the idea
I mean is that why you're doing this is
to inspire students or are you they're
really just to help educate them yeah I
would say that the inspiration part is
is is is like central to what any
teacher does how come you're not gonna
be a teacher if you don't like enjoy it
and if you don't get some sort of
gratitude in helping people have you
ever broken through to someone who
seemed like they were going down the
wrong track yeah I would say so
what was an example of that so you know
the first high school I worked at was
really low economics like low income and
a lot of the students that I got the
chance to work with were like previous
dropouts or like they were there for you
know the past of their parole officer or
something along those lines
so you know when you work with those
kids consistently you get a chance to
kind of help them like basically re
carve out sections of their lives so
that they can like move forward do you
linger on the past do you recall any
moments any turning points for a student
that you were involved with I mean
there's never I've never had that like
great big like does that standard
deliver stand in delivery moment I have
no one's ever like stood in their desk
and like read poetry to me Dead Poets
Society corn lyrics yeah yeah I mean
like corn lyrics maybe um no I've never
had that moment but again like I
wouldn't expect a kid to um to do that
you know I mean I wouldn't have done
that when I was right
as a student ever opened up to you more
than you probably would have wanted them
to or more than you were used to do you
mean like like what do you mean by that
just you know really open their told you
things about their shared shared maybe
too much yeah I would say so and what do
you what how do you respond well you
know if a students willing to open up to
you listen all right and that's the most
important thing that any any student
really probably wants and a teacher is
just like here what is said to them it's
to have someone listen to them I mean
like that's probably the most important
thing as a teacher is just treat
students like people train with respect
and like listen to what they actually
have to say invalidate those opinions
provided they're not like totally insane
how do you deal with troublemakers in
class I just asked him to make a
decision I mean you give people options
and they take whichever option is in
their best in what are the choices they
get like continue to do what you are
doing or do the right thing I guess or
like you have an option of like you know
you're gonna leave the classroom and go
to the principal or whatever or you're
gonna come back here and reset and do
the work but you know I don't want to
make it like punitive do you ever yell
at them I don't really yell I don't like
not at all you take a stern tone though
sometimes I can get to a general Stern
tone can you give me an example of what
it'd be like if you were at your
sternest it'd be really cringe-worthy
did you try yeah it doesn't work in
adults you know what I mean whoa okay
yeah I mean you know it's a there was a
kid right there and he just made a fake
fart noise what would you do maybe it
was a real fart noise you know you can't
you can't discriminate against that I
mean just happens you know oh do you do
that are you the kind of teacher who's
cool with farts well a fart fart man I
can't okay come on
cool well okay so say a student farts
and he makes a purpose of he angles his
cheeks in such a way that it makes the
fart even louder than it needed to be
and do you say you didn't need to make
it that loud yeah I mean I probably
wouldn't say you didn't need to make it
that loud I think we would all know I
mean that's a pretty impressive feat um
I would probably go and like tap the kid
on the shoulder and just say like hey
man I'll talk to you over there
and you know after everyone else like
what if you tap him and it kind of
pushes more out that kids got some like
weird bodily things that's going on
because that's not do you but are you
okay so has anyone this is I know this
seems silly but has anyone ever passed
gas in class and it smelled really bad
that you you've mentioned it while
you're doing teaching oh yeah that comes
up pretty consistent it does what do you
say you were working in a group of like
seventh and eighth graders I mean like
they smell like constantly whether it's
the farting use the juice so you bring
up the smell sometimes so even non fart
smells well yeah so I just body odor
smells yeah so what do you say do you
say somebody didn't wear deodorant today
what's up you say you stink
you should go handle that you say that
in front of class do people like usually
more do people laugh yeah do you get
laughs a lot when you teach I get some
less I get do you actively try to go for
laughs in class not actively I mean it's
just sort of like you know situation
creates some like you seem like a
no-bullshit kind of kind of teacher a
little bit I like to keep it pretty
straightforward yeah I mean like I'm not
I'm not like a strict guy but right now
this stuff we gotta get done so what
what are some other smells that you've
smelled in class besides fart nose but
mostly body odor or like I smell a lot
of like like chips like chips mixed with
things I think smells like chips in
middle school I don't know what flavors
it's mostly the spicy stuff like Cheetos
spicy Cheetos or like what does other
takis tacos do kids come in class to
class with you know red fingers and
stuff pretty consistently yeah yeah
what do you how do you do like that no I
don't like that I mean do ya no eating
in class right
no gum what's the most lenient thing
you've ever done in your class what's
the most you know Oh mr. James is a cool
teacher thing you've done um there's
been a few situations where like we just
like walked outside to play kickball for
an hour well that's why the nicest thing
oh wait wait why did you do that just
because like it was at the end of all
this testing and it was just like there
was no point continuing on yeah yeah I
mean like do you give your students five
like a fight like if high five yeah yeah
I'll give them a high five that's about
as far as like any kind of like like I
don't know physical contact goes yeah
yeah like the hugs come and you kind of
have to like see you avoid hugs
yeah I hate hugs anyway there's all
people sure sure shades other people
right you don't like hugs and Jen yeah
straight up what do you what do they say
what do they do when what do you do when
you see a hug coming no put the hand up
like that really like this yeah and what
do they say that what do they what do
they say this is a react say you know
mr. James that's some kind of weird but
you know it's like you know when you're
a male teacher in any kind of
environment it's like that's just like
rule number one all right don't put your
weight come on do female teachers hug
some of them will yeah what's up with
that I don't know seems seems strange
man strange what if you were going in
for a high five and then you spotted
some talky dust on the end of their
fingers what do you say I would just
pull that pull back okay just kind of
abort this is this is not an emotional
safe space this is more about like you
know I don't want to get talked about so
I mean have you ever thought about the
alternative you see the talky dust and
you go they're going in for the five and
then you just go other hand no switch it
up you leave that polished about it I'd
rather just like you know what child
you're making a poor decision it's gonna
in fact have you ever told a student to
wash their hands really yeah and a grown
I mean an elder student you know kind of
you know high school yes yeah you what
have you what do you say I your hands
are dirty you should go wash them I mean
I don't like well I've got hand
sanitizer in my classroom I mean like
are you a pretty clean person in general
yeah I pretty are you kind of somewhat
are you German conscious I'm a little
German conscious sure you know that bug
stories and that sort of stuff from high
school yeah
I'm sorry may get dead bugs you can get
bedbugs from high schools well I mean
like people can bring them right makes
ya carpets there so that that's going
around these days
the bedbugs yeah the bedbugs are going
around these days you know but in high
schools well I mean just anywhere
anything I mean that's a congregation of
people we've got markets uh-huh yeah
bugs education and how do you feel like
you don't do did you use to get sick a
lot now you don't or what yeah so that's
like one of the major benefits of like
working in schools is just like your
immune system feels like like it's just
been jerry-rigged just withstand like
some pretty powerful Wow like some
pretty powerful diseases I feel that's
cool students ever try to talk to you
about young stuff and you do relate to
it I'm talking video games and oh yeah
movies and stuff I would say that's one
of the advantages I had teaching is that
I'm not old enough to have forgotten
what it was like to be like you know 16
17 18 right but like what's sort of
strange about is you start to see how
the things that you liked and like the
music you listen to are so painfully out
of date okay something that you master
as like a little as a year ago like in
terms of like their pop culture
knowledge right it's just like dead on
arrival for the next year right so
really you're really just it's it's a
constant battle to are you like in class
like saying things are on fleek like
right now and I try to avoid that and
they're like oh that's kind of last year
yeah I said it once and I got I got some
dirty looks yeah I mean that was a
phrase that was popular for like
literally a week yeah it was immediately
uncool yeah yeah so it's better to just
sort of like try and try to above the
fray but right yeah yeah we're all the
teachers are just like walking time
capsules have really interesting so do
you what's the most embarrassing really
embarrassing in class and you how did
you react to it and then did you laugh
about it when you were in the teachers
lounge later so one time I had a kid
this is before I was a teacher I was
like and I was a I was an aide but I was
still like you know I got an assistant
teacher in the classroom there's a kid
that would consistently
like pisses pants to get out of class
and he would always do it yeah like
whenever the the test came around so
when we about like a standardized test
I'd be like I go to the bathroom and you
would call on him to go and he would
always just happen to piss how old was
the student he was this was a I believe
he was a sixth graders like on the walk
to the bathroom he'd be pissing on it
was in the classroom in the class it was
straight up just I mean it was like a
like a thing where he would just try and
get out of stuff was did he wear shorts
usually when this happened or he would
have pants I think that it was a range
of different clothes so he would do this
with shorts on sometimes it sometimes
what would your response be you know
it's one of those things where you have
to just treat it as profession as you
can because I'm like you can't tell a
kid that you did that on purpose
Nestle's right pattern he's going to a
pretty drastic measures yeah this is
that he doesn't have to take that test
Wow so what would the how would the
teacher handle that kid it's one of
those things where you pick up the kid
you send them to the nurse to change
that sort of stuff but I mean like the
test is kind of invalidated at that
point of time so did he get bad grades
suffice to say after this after the
second or third time of doing this did
you guys just require that he wear a
diaper in class especially on test day
there was no diaper mandates placed on
the child and fortunately I think
parents were kind of opposed that's that
have a meeting with the parents about it
yeah well yeah I mean it comes up that's
a long time can I ask you this have you
ever been frustrated with a student who
was being defiant to the point where you
wanted to spank him or something I've
never wanted to spank him as a but you
ever have you ever wanted it have you
ever gotten really upset with a student
that you were you kind of wish there was
a paddle involved yeah I mean like I I
think that I've always there's been like
situations where I felt that but I would
never like act on that of course yeah
it's it's actually you know Arizona has
like some sort of like long-lost mandate
that allows for a like corporal Polly
yeah like you could pull out a paddle
what you got approval from like every
administrator and like load I thought
really yeah it's like technically like
some backlog law so you you've had
fantasies of paddling no well I mean not
in any sexual way but I mean in a way
that you were
for frustration you were like look it up
the laws that's right a figure you know
I just really you know I really have a
lot of like paddling fantasies when it
comes to like you know outdated outdated
Arizona yeah right as being a teacher
made you more or less interested in
having kids you know that's the one
thing that is like I feel like I still
like all the kids okay you know I know
that like teachers kind of get that
stigma where it's like oh yeah this is a
bad kid this bags like shoot that
matters like even like the most
difficult because you have like you
really do like right right so I would
say it was probably increased my okay
the likely that I would have you ever
lost your cool in in front of class but
I lost her cool I mean you know you were
up you were having trouble with a kid
and he pushed the wrong button with you
and you said some things or you just
lost you lost control yourself and maybe
said something you've handled things the
wrong way I feel like every teacher does
that some points in time and if they
don't then they're probably either not
remembering correctly or they're they're
they're line up so what was an example
of when you lost control there's just
some kids like this is early on in my
career I feel like there are some kids
that were just like specifically defined
because they felt like you were just
like yeah kind of like lording your
authority over them and then you know
they're just they're done with that
basically hmm
so I kid he just like refused to work
just like shook his head kind of you
know derisively
after I kept asking him over and over
again to like just get this this one
thing done and you know I kicked him out
of the room he didn't leave the room you
just sort of like you know leaned back
in the chair like I don't know if you
watch sorry what was his style uh get
backwards hat you know you know Miami
Heat Jersey okay got it
yeah you know you can infer what you
will from like I guess those two things
yeah yeah and like he was just he was
not having it so I didn't like freak out
on him or anything like that but I
remember like like I definitely told him
like like afterwards I kind of I guess
but I guess the failure in my part was
like giving it a little bit so you let
him just stay there because I wasn't
doing I'm not gonna
physically move the kid right right and
why can't you can you call or call
somebody boo is almost at the end of the
like the period yeah time and it was
just like it probably would have just
been making a scene but at the same time
it's like you can't really like being
consistent about this but it's tough
because if you call someone it makes you
look like you're not an authority figure
it's like no I can't handle this maybe
not necessarily though I mean maybe it
was like he you know students know that
he can he can't physically do anything
so it's hey I'm gonna call do you think
early in your career that some students
could kind of like sniff out that you
were new and they kind of like took
advantage of that yeah I mean like I
don't look like the oldest guy and when
I first started working I mean I was
like I said I was working with these
like kind of impoverished kids right
right there with probation officers and
requirements so like I'm walking into a
classroom as like a 24 year old right
and they're like 20 different from yeah
half the time they're just like really
like this guy's not gonna tell me what
to do right so have you ever sent any
bad words into class on accident or on
purpose not like not really now never
said the F word no no said the F word in
class H word though never said the SH
would what about the B word never said
the B word Wow
well like you know in terms of like
literature like sometimes you read a
book and it's got some like it's got bad
words all right that's the that's the
gotta get that's the loophole comes a
literature and stuff yeah keep it
authentic you know what do you what's
your curriculum like what do you what
are you usually what are you teaching
these seventh and eighth graders right
now uh you know you learn a lot a lot of
like classics I would say but you know
like so we read a lot of like the older
novels you guys buy read like capture
the Flies and that so yeah remember all
those types of guys and then you know
the way that standards work these days
there's a lot of like informational
texts and those sorts of things it takes
the fun right out it has has anything is
there anything that you want to teach or
you know read in class and the school
won't allow you to do that like stuff
that's maybe outdated because there was
stuff about like Mark Twain stuff right
didn't they do they want to ban that or
something like that
it's a good point um I'd have to think
about that one there's a lot of like
there's a lot of classic books I think
would be really good like even catcher
the Rye is hard to like swing in a
classroom these days really yeah the
schools have problems with that now
there's a lot of them that are on the
banned books list you have to just sort
of like walk on eggshells depending on
what you're gonna provide he's catching
the riot book that you really want kids
to read in a grade or whatever I think
it'd be a good one for some of those for
like high school students because it's a
lot about like you know self-expression
so you you you have oh yeah you are
going well do you pick your curriculum
like guys they're like a list of books
that you're allowed to choose from and
you create what you want or is it a bit
more free there's a bit more up to you
or you basically where you based it off
of what's available in the you base it
up what's available in the in the
curriculum and I'm sorry I'm sorry in
the in the like libraries and that sort
of stuff is that like state-by-state is
that different so yeah it's state
standards but it's really just like what
schools have available to them at a
point I'm okay maybe I think maybe talk
just a little closer to our is that
right Mike Aaron or doesn't matter he's
good where he is oh you're actually good
video sorry and so is catch from the
riot book that you died you do like you
like to teach right and you have taught
yeah not that book really cuz I've never
had like access to it yeah oh really the
band it's it's not it's not available a
lot of libraries and like it's managed
by some some schools but you know that's
just school by school really speaking I
mean you can go to like some
conservative schools in like um the
South and you're gonna find like Harry
Potter band or something right so you
just it's just based off of whatever the
district people teach Harry Potter I've
never seen someone teach Harry Potter
someone has a student ever expressed you
that they really connected or got
inspired by a piece of literature
yeah I've heard that before yeah what
was an example of that so um you know
like it's more like I've recommended
certain books to them and they've found
those really kind of like inspiring in
some ways that kid with the corn yeah
definitely yeah he would what was it he
read Little Women is that true the corn
kid okay and the what was what was a
book that really hit home with somebody
let's see I remem
prescribing perks of being a wallflower
to a kid really appreciated that because
there's all about like you know
loneliness yeah and she really she
really took that one that's cool she
blossomed from that I don't actually
blossom from it but she seemed to really
enjoy and she said that it was like
connecting med school that's nice I'm
really passionate about English
literature yeah I mean like I studied
literature that's how I got into
teaching sure sure yeah did you know you
wanted to be a teacher or did that kind
of happen sort of fell into it what's
your favorite period of literature yeah
so it's kind of shifted a lot because I
mean like back in like when I was in
college I used to like like all the new
stuff I really like all the
postmodernist yeah but like these days
new stuff is it doesn't quite carry as
much as some of the classics do so I
still really like a lot of the modernist
stuff I would say uh-huh so that's your
kind of focus yeah and then for you
personally yeah and I'm really I really
like all the realistic works like a lot
of the Hemingway is really great a lot
of English people my English people are
many people who are you know study
English and college and stuff
Shakespeare as always they're sort of
you know go to that's their favorite is
that the same case for you or you know I
wouldn't say it you know to move on
anything I wouldn't say it's a go-to but
I mean like do you think Shakespeare is
overrated
oh I wouldn't say is overrated it's just
like it's one of those things where the
guy developed so many interesting ideas
over a period of time and he's the
father of so many great ideas providing
existed if he did that you have to look
at it in order appreciate anything
that's being done now right but it
doesn't mean that you have to
necessarily love what it was though you
appreciate where it came has never had a
like a boner in class before I'm sure
that they have but I haven't I mean
never like nobody like you never brought
ask somebody to write something on
chalkboard and then the kid said no I
can't come up and they said no come on
just come up and then he did come up and
it was just pretty really never happens
never know I you know maybe I'm just not
observant that's right right you're not
looking for it I guess I'm asking if
there was a thing where you couldn't
help but notice because it was just so
obvious I've never had like an
unnoticeable like like a boner that just
there's just too much yeah right it
didn't just like break the class Brent's
looking for boners he's wondering like
if they're around in school
we gotta find a right place to find him
you know what's your favorite period in
school but even period in school well he
said what's a fair period of literature
something like what's your favorite zero
zero through seven oh it's probably uh
like third period third period it's
break break
let's break yeah oh there oh you mean
that's your frequency my previous oh
that's okay okay say say you didn't have
a free period what's your favorite
period it's definitely really terrible
Oh what about sixth period though that's
kind of nice right it's terrible oh
they're just staring at the clock well
you know it's like when you get to the
end of the day they're at the end of
those people or do you ever look at the
clock to thinking I can't wait to get
out of this absolutely what it is I mean
like you know is I feel like I mean I
think that's like it's a work that's
been done right everyone gets most their
best work done before lunch yeah yeah
it's also funny that it seems like the
same thing happens to like hearing about
what students you like working with the
most needs like seventh grade is the
most the ones you like the most which is
like earlier an earlier period and then
you said 12th grade they're kind of the
worst and it's kind of like the same
thing through the day it's mirrored
through the years you see what I mean
yeah I would say so interesting yeah
yeah try and get out of there it's when
you're about to like leave for anything
whether it's in a day or like after four
years right right why you're excited
yeah we're done we're all done so
remember that so the teachers lounge
talk about it the teachers lounge it's
um
it's a real real sad place for the most
part you know there goes one of two ways
that either sort of like falls apart
into just like like you know banter and
that sort of stuff gossip gossip or it
turns into just like the most rants it's
like like like [ __ ] fast as you can
really about the students or about the
the principal and stuff like just
anything you know it's just that's
reasonable of anyway like the the
district and stuff could be anything it
doesn't matter what it is you know
people just complain there any drama
between the teachers
oh I'm sure yeah not you don't get
involved with that actually I see my
room man oh you don't you let students
eat in your room
yes sometimes uh-huh but not off like
The Wallflowers yeah a little
so you have you used you have hung out
at with the teachers during lunch and
stuff sure sure do you make friends with
those teachers or now I mean sort of
yeah they're co-workers right are there
you find that it's hard to connect to
the other teachers because maybe there's
different ages and stuff or I mean like
it's just like any workplace sometimes
you just find certain people that I knew
same age do you have any good buddy good
friends that are from work a friend do
you become friends with the other
faculty oh yeah absolutely
you mean like like the like the
maintenance guy sure oh yeah yeah
you can be nice to those guys honestly
like the librarians are like the second
most powerful people in school really
oh yeah it's like White House who's the
most powerful the principal principals
much yeah why number two and then like
that librarians by far I'm sorry who's
number two the like the assistant
principal your vice president oh yeah
and are there more than one branch
principals one uh-huh and why is the
librarian so powerful as she he or she
holds the keys to like what whether you
get anything in the school so they're
charged with the books that you get for
your exactly books technology it's all
checked out through the library and so
librarian holds quite a few does your
school have like iPads and stuff we've
got some like advanced not advanced
technology we got some likes like
Chromebooks smart books those sorts of
things you do do you ever do anything
extra nice for the librarian or the
principal in order to help
oh yeah things that you need for your
classes people suck out this what you
guy do
yeah really so you do that you suck up
oh yeah what did you do suck I'll bring
the librarian like a like a Christmas
card and things like that little gift
here there compliments those sorts of
things really yeah and it works yeah
okay to my main my classroom gets taken
care of
Wow so do you think that it some
teachers don't who don't do this kind of
stuff they don't get taken care of the
same way I think that you have to make
sure that you're taking care of the
right people to be taken care of
Wow so are some teachers classrooms
filthy because they the bane of sky is
not really the low on the priority list
or they have like you know lights that
are out and stuff like yeah they're low
on the priority list Wow no one's
getting to them
when did you realize that oh this is the
way to do it you gotta I was low on the
priority yeah dirty room and nothing was
gonna fix
so what clique what do you think you're
like thinking how many how did you
realize okay maybe I need to start you
just start going to the people that you
need help with and then you notice if
you're nicer to them and offer them
things they like you know eventually
start to come around see that's just the
principle of a power trip nah our
principle she's a really nice lady she's
pretty she's pretty like have you ever
had a weird principle um yeah I've had a
weird principle for I don't principal
who was like kind of a like a game
fanatic like just like video games okay
person uh hi and it's like like late 40s
okay yeah and you would just like go
home and drink himself stupid and play
video games over really yeah so we would
like like this is back like the first
job I had you like call the guy to like
open up the school and it would just be
like really he's got drunk is playing
really in World of Warcraft what
happened did he get fired no no it was
like a charter so no yeah did he like
talk to students about video games and
stuff oh yeah yeah did you play games
with students no I don't know maybe
online or something but I'm really crazy
are you allowed to have online you know
like relationships with students for the
purposes of helping them outside of
school kind of only if it's like through
like formal channels like if you've got
like a you know like a forum or
something or something like it can be
monitored by do you have a Facebook ID
Facebook do your kids try to add you or
do you ever yeah yeah bye guys do you
have a Facebook fan page which is for
students only I use just fake things for
everything big names yeah so are there
what have you ever you know you said
there is gossip between teachers right
or ma'am do they ever gossip about the
students oh yeah did you hear what
happened to Ritchie or whatever you know
they take care about the students is
there cause they care about that stuff
like the students drama yeah that
stuff's interesting now you like it - oh
it's interesting stuff because they mean
like you know you've we've all been
there right so it's just like you know
they're just kind of coming into the
yeah and you know these kids but in a
different context and what they're do
you go to the dances I mean like we
monitor them ya know i know i yeah i
mean you go there just chaperone or
whatever so do some teachers and
yourself included do you like do they
feel like they're reliving the the past
kind of when they get to go to the
dances or do they do they look at it as
a social opportunity as well the sense
that like um like they're terrible no no
I mean is it all my experiences at
dances were just terrible so oh really I
still regard them as terrible so maybe
yeah in that regard I'm absolutely
necessary nightmare over and over yeah
yeah I mean I guess there's some student
teachers get excited about the dances
more not for the students but for
themselves and they kind of like the
idea of kind of getting dressed up maybe
and maybe socializing and I've never
seen a teacher get excited for a dance
because it's mostly just work yeah it's
just like another yeah it's like I got a
stay late for this anything weird ever
happened at a dance I mean like there's
a lot of like bathroom duty stuff where
it's like you're pulling kids out of the
bathroom and that kind of stuff because
they're drunk wait you know people doing
naughty things in the bathroom that's
surprising I'm sorry what
yeah it's surprising but oh they do yep
that's why that's the job of the like
that's the job what about you what are
they doing in the bathroom during nandi
I mean people were using the bathroom to
go to the bathroom are they using it for
other things during school regular
school I mean I'm sure they're using it
for all sorts of different purposes it's
not your really your job yeah have you
ever give your own bathroom teachers
bathroom there's tons of teachers
bathroom thank you have you ever
suspended a kid from your class are you
allowed to do that I mean like I'm not
allowed to do that I can recommend it
and then like they go through a process
where that determines whether they get
suspended or not you how often are you
sending kids to the principal's office I
don't send them very often oh really
yeah I don't send have you ever yelled
mmm I really kind of screamed to the kid
yeah but not not like not not crazy I
mean like I've raised my voice right I
mean but I haven't really like lost it
like I said the worst
Ben is like basically giving in to the
kiddos right like freaking out on me all
right mm-hmm
do you when you watch like highschool
coming-of-age movies and TV shows and
stuff right now do you like them more
now that you're a high school teacher or
less or do you do you connect with those
films in a certain way it's funny
because they're so inaccurate oh really
across the board if they're any accurate
ones um no not that I've seen not a
single one well I mean like they're just
the dramatized and they write the thing
that's like kind of funny about like any
kind of like coming about what about the
class of 1999 yeah it's very unrealistic
most of the time like when you see those
things they have like real narrative
clarity it's like grinding and people
have grown around point where they've
like you know emotionally stepped up a
level but like Messier yeah really yes
okay are there any teachers that come to
the school and they want to be they want
to be edward james olmos or they want to
be michelle pfeiffer I don't think they
want to be no I mean Janet does anyone
kind of go in there with these
unrealistic you know movie expectations
like I'm gonna change the world yeah
kind of yeah that happens and other than
you guys and that's that's one of the
reasons that like the new guys are like
that yeah new people come in they want
to do all these like you know
life-changing things yeah that's noble
it's a noble thing and realistic uh you
know it's that that that passion is
important right right it's referred to
have it right but like I mean
realistically speaking it's not like a
grand gesture type thing it's kind of
kind of in between the two have you ever
have you had many kids where you really
really were trying to I don't know
changes their life or make make them you
know stop making mistakes and they just
you couldn't and they just kind of kept
going down a bad path yeah you work on
everybody as best you can
yeah I mean that's the best you can do
right yeah so like you know you give a
kid all the time you've got right
everything you've got but you know
there's still people have you ever had
to visit their home no you never done
that no it's kind of like have you ever
had to do that cousin has any student
ever tried to mess with you in a violent
way or you mean like like like played
tricks on me or like or vandalize your
stuff or you know do your classroom or
your car maybe or something no nothing
to that extent I mean like simple
vandalism
but not in the sense of like it's myself
right on that stupid s everywhere
Superman it's the s yes it's kind of
like crack to kids I don't know they
can't say have you ever caught have you
ever caught someone passing notes in
class sure and have you ever read them
yeah sometimes we'll read them out loud
oh what's the juiciest it's something
really you don't go for it no no I mean
obviously sometimes it's like it's too
juicy you save it for later yeah
Jared over like take these juicy notes
and then bring them back home or share
them with the teachers and say this
person wrote oh yeah I mean I'll take if
it's a really big deal I'll take it to
like the council or something like that
but I don't like what's it what's in it
what's a big deal oh like if it's like
something like graphically sexual or so
oh yeah that's just I mean just for the
sake of interest here what what was what
was an example of something that was
graphically though like something that
was explicit like like the first year I
started working there was like some
pretty egregious like [ __ ]
solicitations and things like asking for
one like a boy asking a girl or was it a
girl who would have given of whatever
you think it was like just kind of
sexual harassment style I don't think it
was sexual harrass okay you think it's
learning I think so you know interesting
uh-huh and well what are the what's an
example of one you would read in front
of class the ones that are pretty like
inane for the most part what are you
doing after lunch today oh my god this
is so boring that kind of stuff mm-hmm
that stuff's easy to read in winter
class when students are whispering to
each other something and you're
lecturing are you do you ever stop and
say what are you guys talking about
yeah what do they say nothing do you
ever force people to answer questions
when they don't want to answer yeah
that's the game that's a game whole game
eglee well I mean like they don't want
to always answer well okay like what
percentage the class generally wants to
raise their hand you know maybe a
quarter a quarter less than a quarter
and you purposely try to ask students
who aren't raising their
on stuff oh yeah yeah I have to all
right are there any kids who are super
nervous in class oh yeah no what's up
with that how do you deal with that I
don't know you just love you think it's
funny it's kind of funny yeah I mean
help them you ever laugh about stuff in
private like you ever make fun of kids
sometimes when you're outside of the
class in public or in private in private
when you're yeah of course yeah I mean
like you know not in a way that's like
horrible but you know I mean like just
realistic sometimes kids even make fun
of kids in public yeah like not in ways
that I hope are like you know destroying
them like emotionally and crippling them
for the future
like I just silly kind of silly kind of
they're laughing with you I just has a
student ever thrown up in class in the
trash can but not like I don't know just
got sick but usually if they say like I
need to go the bathroom to throw up you
just let them go the bad but it did
happen before did that gross you out it
was pretty gross did other kids get
grossed out
yeah I think they were pretty gross did
anyone else want to throw up because of
that didn't they didn't like trigger
some sort of like you know calm domino
domino effect but you know I guess I
guess it could have how many students
are in your class is about 33 kids okay
is that a lot or that's kind of yeah oh
it is you were a classroom that you're
teaching 33 kids take 30 what would you
prefer Oh like 20 27 or something like
that's probably pretty good in big
public high school you're right it's
public yeah yeah
you ever play sports with any of the
students I'll shoot baskets with them
sometimes you yeah okay I have a
question it's a bit so okay look like
we're where are we real quick just out
here sometimes
oh okay Wow okay I mean I'm liking this
but I'm like yeah well yeah I just have
a question so okay so I think I you know
on the internet these days and I think
we've all read a lot of articles in the
news and stuff about like woke identity
politics stuff kind of being a big part
of college campuses mm-hmm have you
found that that's the case at all with
high school or does that not really
matter or even middle school identity
politics with regards to what can be
specific just like people you know like
let's see we talk about are there any
like transgender students at your school
oh yeah yes
no I'm not asking that I mean like a
strong one is sir I mean a strong
concern about like being PC or like
saying things that might offend someone
like there's just a lot of Oh like is
that is that is that a conversation
that's being had I guess that is my
question yes so it doesn't come across
necessarily as this um it doesn't come
across like as that conversation okay
right it comes across in the you know
like some people will not be comfortable
with other people like making jokes or
like writing incorrect whatever like
pronouns right right right right and
then some will call them out on it right
and then it creates the whole the
controversy of like where's the line
between allowing someone to say
something a little bit risque or like
expressing themselves as opposed to like
you know respecting someone else's like
rights have you ever been accused of
saying something inappropriate in class
not like super inappropriate I mean like
and no one has ever gotten angry at me
for using incredible where the
administration and her like the
principal how do I talk to you for some
reason no not really
right yeah how do other teachers get in
trouble why what do they do well it's
more just like you know like if a parent
gets involved in like feels that a
student was not treated appropriately
something along those lines and you know
the principal have them come in and
discuss that with them because you know
you have to just the concern of the
parent valid or not valid you have to
double-check right right have teachers
ever fought with each other in school
like what yeah never seen a physical
teacher fight mm-hmm I mean like still a
lot of time left I'm hoping abuses have
you seen have you had there been verbal
fights yeah they're yelling at each
other
uh like quietly and I've seen like no
there was one where like a lady had to
get a restraining order against some guy
another teacher yeah but I was like it
was it had nothing to do like on campus
that was more like you know did they
both went to the same school
yeah then one had to move the gentleman
had to move was he like stalking her or
something I didn't even know exactly
what was going on I got the feeling that
like because they used to be like kind
of friendly so I think something
happened yeah I mean if you wanted to
take it a step further I don't know
but I mean they had classes that were
like next to each other so eventually it
was like well someone's gotta be are
their romances that happen in the school
oh yeah I'm between teachers yeah that
happens yeah you see a lot of teachers
that are doing this we think I'm a lot
of the people that start working at
schools I mean they show up and they
just start working like right out of
college
yeah there's no there's no preparation I
mean like what's the preparation for
going into a high school or is it just
like you all of a sudden our teacher
like how much you mean like you work as
an aide a little bit right I worked as
an aide but like I only get some kids
who are some teachers who they'll go
through the 4-year program and their
fourth year they usually spend like half
that a classroom where they just get to
observe and like kind of seven lessons
have you ever seen any teacher-student
relationships ever happen oh you mean
like talk to you read about in the news
yeah no I've never seen that I mean like
you know you hear these stories like
from other places but I've never seen
anything like this it's kind of a dark
question but they have you ever heard of
male teacher or actually it could be
male or female it talked about a student
you know say an older student so it's
not as dark of a question say like a you
know as a 17 18 year old student have
you ever heard them talk about that
student in a sort of you know suggestive
way or whatever I've never heard of that
like I've never had it like a another
teacher come to being like drop that way
and say again walk away that's never
Ryan Cibrian today tank top was just
can't stop stop seeing Brian right now
Brides looking swall today is Brian do
you go to games um yeah I got a games do
you have school pride I might try to
have school you got themselves you had
do you have more school pride now than
you did when you were a student there's
no doubt that I do yes really
yeah I had no school pride was really a
bad student as a student I was like that
was a decent suit you don't get in
trouble or I was not not too much but I
was kind of one of those students that
just sort of like coasted by for the
most so when you finished high school if
you would if you had if someone told you
then like dude you're gonna be back in
high school a bunch later you'd be like
no way I'm done I'm over it I don't know
close the door and anything but it was
just one of those things worse like I
regarded high schools pretty easy at the
time and so it was never something that
was really to oppression okay do you
wear school apparel yeah so have you
ever worn your school shirt for your
school and look at yourself in the
mirror and just thought what have I
become
I mean yeah based on based on your old
self not having school spirit oh yeah
now that existential crisis is like a
weekly experience really Wow
so does it it trips you out sometimes oh
yeah really
because teachers is people when you're
younger you regard the teachers as like
this staunch stalwart individuals but
like as an adult it's just like you're
just a person trying to get your your
day to day and right no no all right
give it to us straight to teachers look
down upon substitute teachers yes they
do you do a Stickley Wow oh yeah yeah
talk about that well I mean like things
where it's like you know I don't you
think of them as not real teachers
depends some of them used to be - yeah
things were you kind of like um you
allow a substitute teacher to come in
like the expectation is that like
nothing will ultimately get done right
it's really you should just provide like
coloring sheets at best for the surprise
teacher and like lessons that will
basically not result in the school being
burned down and anything beyond that is
just their babysitter their glorified
baby
it's like let's say that the teachers
weren't like good at some point in time
right are they the expectation of the
sub is not high it are they are their
subs that are really good that you that
you want oh yeah so like that's the
thing it's like there are some subs that
are outstanding and they will come in
and just like they'll crush the
classroom really I teach actual lessons
yeah just like wow so how does a how
does it how does this I mean I don't
know if you know how to answer this but
how does the substitute teacher may this
is a different episode but how does the
substitute teacher able to teach a class
you know not having you know not really
knowing where they are I mean not having
you know just jumping in all of a sudden
like blunt-force I would say you come in
and just like lay down the law it seems
like that's but most of them do do
students do you find that the students
really don't respect the substitute
teachers I think that they look for
opportunities to like circumvent the
stuff yeah like it's just like you're
constantly poking holes in the defense's
but do you have a favorite student no
not really you don't have favorites I
know everyone assumes that everyone's
got a favorite Sunnah but I don't think
that's necessarily true I think some
people have a lot of favoritism but like
I really do like all the students right
like I really that's that's that's
something so how many periods you teach
yeah like a hundred students right now
are like hundred fifty five well I teach
yeah I got 550 kids yes do you have a
least favorite student yeah yeah you do
oh yeah but I mean like I still like
that student right you want him to
succeed I want her to succeed
oh okay feel like you know it is like
why she what is it about her that makes
sure yeah it's just one of those things
whereas like they complain a lot and
they like make excuses do you think
other teachers would call her their
least favorite - or just she just bad
with English with English class I'm sure
that other people would regard wow
really yeah so you guys talk about this
is some of the stuff you guys talk about
in the teachers lines when you are
hanging out yeah but there's always like
the underlying assumption it's just like
but you so they try your best right all
right yeah what's the most rewarding
what's the one single most rewarding
experience you had as a teacher it's
like watching them graduate and walk
away it's real nice oh really well I
mean like especially it's like when you
work at like a high school and you watch
them through that have you ever cried
because of it cried is it something sad
but because you were happy or proud like
I've seen like um like some African
refugees come through and like graduate
or they basically spoke no English upon
entry well I'm like they really work you
know they worked their asses off for
that and that was really nice especially
cuz they have like these big families
that are just like cheer like crazy for
me you don't start you don't ever do
English second language classes right
yeah I don't
yeah
okay so yeah I don't know should we
should we I kind of feel we can like
kind of just keep going with whatever
you want to do keep going with James
here or yeah we had this idea we would
have like a primary guest and then if
there were some people who showed up to
you know check out the recording that
way we would do some rapid fire
interviews with some of them but man
unless there's anything else you want to
cover with James maybe we could do that
I mean I think if I have any other
questions this has been very informative
yeah nope okay here's one one of the
question real quick what's the what's
the biggest what's the dirtiest you know
like when I say dirty I don't mean
what's the dirtiest secret about
teaching high school or or and junior
high yeah that's a good way and I bet I
don't mean dirty I don't mean like
sexual but just what's the what's the
juiciest secret about it what do we what
do we not what a common folk not knowing
about the dirty is secret yeah well no
no I mean like it's pretty much I was
there any correct is there is there ever
any corruption like rampant corruption
going on with test scores or something
like that something like that or like
about money money related stuff with
this budget I mean like not not as it
pertains to like like like the public
schools that I work in but like you know
sometimes like a lot of the charter
schools are not exactly on the level I
would say and some of them are
outstanding you never seem like budgets
are being used for the wrong things well
so I've been in it I've seen charter
schools where like you know attendance
attendance is not reported correctly in
those sorts of oh yeah you know they get
money for hire you'll see some things
where it's like kids again dropped in
dropped off shipped in shipped out just
in time for like tests or brought in
just for to you know things like how do
you feel about standardized tests I
dislike them oh really yeah you think
they don't represent their pretty
terrible do you make an effort to prep
kids for the standardized tests or do
you just sort of not put a lot of
importance on those tests I put
importance on them because that's the
job yeah because you get your school
gets money based on those scores right I
do but it's more like
know this you can make an argument that
the tests are based off of like what
you're supposed to be teaching him
anyways so it's like it should be some
sort of litmus for them right right
especially like you know so so basically
there is some validation but I mean
ultimately like when it's just a test
tests are the English thing this ones
are like reading comprehension tests
right like the SAT right are you you do
you like sports in general yeah you did
you did when you were younger
mm-hmm okay so it wasn't a stretch for
you to become interested in the sports
of the school that you work at yeah
exactly
right okay yeah yeah would you work at a
private school ever I know you worked at
charter but would you work it like a
kind of like a fancy private school or
is that not partying I feel like the
world the wealthy or the kids the more
difficult job because really I kind of
feel so you feel like lower income kids
were easier they're easier to deal with
they're more grateful when you work with
them I'll say that interesting you you
haven't really worked with you haven't
worked with private school kids before
right um I've not worked with like
upper-class private school kids before
but you're basing it off of like the
wealthier kids in your classes are kind
of a [ __ ] are they the ones who are
more defiant they're they're a little
more entitled entitled yeah I mean I
probably have you ever been okay so no
gang has other gang members in your
classes I mean like I'm sure there are
none of them have ever scared you down
and it's never been a situation where
it's like well not now anyway but like
you know previously definitely have you
ever had a student it doesn't matter if
they're gang member or not they could be
some you know upper-class entitled
student however they were just sat in
class and just stared stared at you you
know just like lovingly know you know
like lovingly is you know like a
sarcastic statement but no yeah like
they're just like looking at you like
this their their head is tilted down
like this and they're just looking at
you like dogging you yeah hardcore
dogging yeah yeah I don't not really I
mean like I'm not really much of an
authoritarian so most of the time I can
get around that sort of stuff have you
ever made a kid cry yeah I made a cake
okay what happened there I just you know
I've made fun of some kid just sort of
like passingly making fun of the game
whoa what what what was going on would
you make fun of them uh it was
just like it was just like we were
making fun of like the jobs that the kid
like people would have and those sorts
things like kid was like you know like
what is my job gonna be and it's like
doctor what's your mind you be lawyer
and I told her I was like I said you'll
probably like I say I think I told him
he was gonna like scrape gum off like
chairs or so no just jokingly yeah he
didn't take it so well
Wow how old was he uh he was like is
he's pretty young I guess he was
probably like when he's like six years
old yeah yeah Park do you happen to know
what his job is now I have no idea okay
wait he's so he cried I mean like eating
like like all uncontrolled tear came to
his dad he looks at what did you say
were you at all I'm sorry is joking just
joking don't is joking have you ever
made somebody start bawling no I never
made someone like Paul uncontrollably
have you ever seen tears though from
somebody I mean like not from things
I've said yeah like they'll people will
cry in class you might kids fight with
each other in class have you ever seen a
kid get their test back and they look at
the score and then they start crying
I've never seen them start crying and
controllably but you know they clearly
looked distraught sometimes can you
pinpoint the kids in your class who are
nerds they stand out right right do are
you are you yeah are you welcoming to
the Nerds or you do you think they're
nerds I mean like there's no litmus test
I don't know you could take a look a d20
or something and they'd probably be like
yeah other nerds do the nerds ever get
annoying
um I mean no more or less than anybody
there's any overachievers that I get
annoying yeah sometimes really yeah you
know they're just raising their hand
every time yeah a little bit anyone
sucking up to you
mmm I need any kids suck up to you yeah
I like that as you know I brought you an
apple no one's brought me an apple every
candy gifts at all I'll get candy but no
apples no app not a single one I don't
want an apple you know okay I mean I
really want to I really speaking I don't
really do you have a fake apple in your
class no do you decorate your classroom
with I mean like sort of you don't have
a chalkboard right it's dry erase board
no it's gyrase boy absolutely do you
miss the chalkboard No
I don't think I've actually ever been in
a classroom with like a straight-up
chalkboard do any kids read on Kindles
no no great sonic Kindle kids any read I
guess you have kids who can't read I
know they could I mean like varying
levels of read I mean someone can read
better than others some do you hate like
cliff notes and stuff that's fine you
don't care really well I mean think
about it like yeah you live in a world
now where the student can look up
anything they want to at any point all
right all right
you make them read it but ultimately
like there they should just figure out
how to use the resources in addition to
whatever you're asking how has the
internet changed
the way kids learn as opposed to when
you were a kid student information is
instantaneous I mean how does it affect
teaching do you think well the fact that
they can look anything up means that
like you don't teach them to memorize
anything right you're just like how do
you utilize what you've got in front of
you so I mean this isn't really coming
to play I guess for you I mean
kids don't even take do they take tests
in your class because or they just
writing essays they do both oh you do
have tests of course do you allow
internet access during tests no have you
ever had to take phones away from kids
yeah I'm sure all the times awful yes
until the end of the classroom yeah
usually that's what happened caught
somebody using their phone and there was
a picture on it that disturb you I try
not to look at them yeah that's like
just for your unlike benefit just don't
don't open do you have any kids who
don't have phones yeah really do they
want phones and their parents won't get
them ready there are they kind of
rebelled and I kind of don't want it no
they want them just like kind of are
there any really progressive students
who don't want a cell phone they don't
like the what it's doing to their their
generation you know yeah Wow not single
one not a single one they like the
phones man yeah I hear ya willing to
give up a car like a lot of kids I want
to drive what's the weirdest thing
you've had to confiscate I don't know
about anything weird that I've had to
compensate Compton comp this skate
nothing too weird
yeah just like a Android phone or
something phones and just like you know
hundreds of digits spinners over the
last three months maybe dude does the
is there anyone who has to come in it's
finished
observe your class or evaluate your
class sure yeah how often does that
happen a couple times a year who does
that the principal principal yeah do you
get nervous during that time um yeah
to degree I guess but not really I mean
as long as you're doing your job it
seems like it's has anything ever
embarrassing happened when there was
someone watching nothing terrible now
what's the most embarrassing thing that
happened to you in a class when you were
teaching have you ever accidentally
farted no I've never accidentally farted
I'm very discreet I'm very okay do you
hold it in do you do you okay no I do
not leave it in you don't hold it in no
but there's like a way you can like move
around in a chair of course yeah so you
are down to fart in class yeah and you
know and but do it discreetly
as long as this is great has anyone ever
caught you know known as ever copy but
well that's not true you know some there
has been a situation we're like you fart
in class and then like someone will
complain about the smell of the fire in
class and and it's you know you did it
and and then and then what are you
thinking when someone says mr. James it
smells in here people for it all the
time in class though so they just think
to pass it off on any other person has
anyone ever thrown a stink bomb down and
I'm not a fart that you know where those
plastic someone brought a little cherry
bomb to school once firework
yes firework and they tried to blow
something up with it but it was
ineffective right they just blew it up
in the bathroom no is there bullying in
your school yeah this bullying that's
that how do you deal with that you know
it's a tricky thing right because like a
teacher can sit in and like tell a
student to like stop it but right
doesn't that's not right that's not the
process
it's it's a communal thing right you can
you can you tell who you know as you can
tell who the Nerds are in the class can
you tell who the bullies are in the
class what about cyber bullying cyber
bullying I mean like what control do you
have over it but is that somebody that's
talked about I mean like we discuss it
people will like discuss bullying all
the time and like we'll talk about
interventions for it but I mean like
it's a tricky thing where what do you
what do you do I can like bring someone
in but
they are doing that on their own time
right where's the border between you are
there are there any bullies that are
good students sure oh really yeah but
it's it's I mean it's not like
traditional bullying where it's like
that kids not beating someone up like in
a park afterwards
are there any thuggish people who are
any thuggish students who are getting
straight A's or do really well uh
thuggish yeah some smart thugs like some
real smart are there any like smart ass
smartass sure sure yeah really yeah I
mean like they get A's maybe not a z'
but B pluses they skate by escape by
they get B's but it's like it's one of
those words like that's a naturally
gifted kid that's smart right did they
choose not throughly are you impressed
by that when they're thuggish but then
they're smart impressed by it you want
to kind of like direct them to something
that's not gonna be terrible right yeah
you talk you try to talk do you try to
do that student and then different sure
sure sure what do you say to them well
you just say it's like hey man like
these are options look at the look at
like when you go to college in those
sorts if you want to go to college do
you think that some of these kids
actually listen to you and change their
mind yeah I think that like in the back
of their mind that they do right it's
not like that they don't it's just that
like kind of the circumstances make it
seem like it's unreasonable right but
it's not like they haven't thought about
it I think it just means that they have
to like cut off a lot of their friends
and family do you have you ever do you
have you known any of these students
long enough to know follow up and see
where they've gone like thuggish ruggish
bone the thuggish ruggish bones have you
ever thought seen where they've gone
gone on to do and if they've changed
their life their path
you know man like I said like a lot of
my used to work with in heist like like
in the like in the right you'll charter
school so I don't know because I mean
I'm not Facebook friends with more
anything like that yeah
has any students ever tried to look you
up I'm not using names right so hard I'm
sorry I don't use my like real names
fake name on Facebook oh oh I'm sorry
you use you use a fake name on Facebook
yeah yeah Oh will you have to yeah you
do yeah I think it's a teacher well I
know something I don't have to guys mean
it I think otherwise you just get hit up
by your students ah yeah okay well so
you've never been found
no one's ever found um some try
but you know you just don't acknowledge
it yeah yeah yeah yeah are there
circumstances that kids seem to be in
like socioeconomically or just their
home life and stuff that's just really
difficult to see and like hard to know
how to help there's some situation you
know like cultures of poverty in those
sores yeah yeah it's like there is no
real way out of it right it seems like
and people are convinced that this is
the only thing that they've got yeah you
see some yeah have you ever had a
student in your class who you thought
this student should be in special ed why
are they here yeah sometimes they
doesn't seem like they should be there
and do you ever get them out of your
class and get them in a special ed class
I mean like you have them investigated
but usually by the time they're like
juniors and seniors in high school and
that sort of stuff it's just like you
know what's an exam what's the make an
example of the way somebody was acting
and I was like a kid shows up and
they're like they're they can't write
and when they mean by that is like you
know that's like they can't functionally
create sentences yeah yeah but you can
tell it's not like well the kids not
done but the kid can't like process that
information has a student ever had a
style or just an outfit that just made
you start laughing you know they walk
into class and you just start cracking
up and just thinking what are these what
are you wearing yeah I mean like what
was the one of those I mean I described
them I mean some whatever they wear
these days it's not I mean it's like
maybe risque or something like that but
they're not like ridiculous but again
you know it's not worse than any other
generational like faux pas has so you've
been teaching for seven years
yeah but have you noticed any change it
like any like long-term changes about
you know they're what kids are wearing
or what they're into or I don't know
what has changed in the last seven years
I guess about what's to change besides
the internet I guess it's probably the
most uh well I mean like the internet
was prevalent back then too but now the
phones the phone the phones yes it's
like you know like seven years ago
people everyone had a phone but it was
like it wasn't like the total reliance
on right now none of your life is in
there yeah
so anything besides that or is that kind
of just that's the most attention spans
continue to decrease really Wow and like
on a side note like just like the type
of media
that people consume is really different
so like you'll get a lot of these people
who are like like movies for example
like no one understands what movies are
we know kids are watching movies watch
movies just like you know everything's
really disposable and quick just
constantly just like something to look
at all right they end up like YouTube
stars and like that's kind of a weird
thing yeah yeah well shoot you know I
mean I feel like at this point like I
don't know if it really makes sense to
you know I don't know how psyched you
guys were getting getting quizzed you
know but you know I feel like you know
it was this this was you know like I
felt you know direction and I was like
okay you know but you know yeah you know
I mean I hope you guys weren't like so
psyched to do that and then like I like
down right now know the way oh yeah yeah
the but no but I mean did you yeah but I
mean I hope this this was this was at
least as least as exciting however well
why do you want to no no I don't care I
mean that's you know we'd have like 10
minutes basically right we did yeah I
don't know I mean this has been really
informal so it stings also it's like
this is a school night right now I mean
don't you need to go right James on his
phone right now just like one of his
kids yeah he's like one of them students
we're not the only ones with like
shortened attention yeah yeah James is a
product of the culture yeah I mean um
yeah what do you think should we should
we wrap it up because yeah we could just
wrap it up yeah do you have school
tomorrow right I got school tomorrow
yeah what time do you usually go sleep I
go sleep at like 10:30 okay okay yeah so
this is kind of you kind of being a bad
boy tonight a little bit I guess so as
far as bad boys but it is Friday
tomorrow though yeah that's true just
gotta get through a little bit go home
get drunk play some Wow Wonder Warcraft
wake up yeah vote was me that's so crazy
that's still so funny to me that the
Prince so the principal was like some
loser basically he's an interesting guy
I don't know you know everyone's got
their vices I guess so do you treat the
female students differently than the
male students is or what what do you
mean like I don't know it's just the way
that you like are they different in high
school are they different are they like
different animals they're all animals I
are they different animals like I mean
is there a different approach to like
dealing with male students as opposed to
female students is there a gender
difference really and in dealing with
students yeah guys like like guys like
to be treated a little bit lighter and a
little bit with them little distance let
let them operate you feel like a macho
thing yeah they just want their autonomy
right and and and the women are
dependent you can talk to them a little
bit more probably like directly I would
say little more clearly I think and more
like the teacher kind of like guys don't
like the teacher right they don't be
told but - yeah but the female students
like to be told what to do I was like
percent Kenny but I mean they like and I
was being serious and they like I was I
think when I talked to female students
it's a lot more like just as a teacher
it's a more direct right right yeah and
like guys I kind of let them like find
their way into would you say that the
female students are usually more mature
than the male students are yeah I would
say so yeah yeah
okay I have this another question with
regards to that oh yeah we slightly
touched on this earlier but are there
any transgender students in your school
um there are so what's that like you
just treat them as you would treat
anybody else I mean like a bathroom
thing it's not like we separate them out
or anything how are they pretty well
accepted in the school I guess I guess
not a question this is my question is is
at this point in time or is transgender
ism pretty you know kind of normal now
at this point is they're like pretty
normalized I mean it's it's it's more
normalized I would say at this point in
time yeah people are pretty accepting I
mean like I guess we've never really had
I've never really encountered anything
hate crimes right right yeah like that
it seems like yeah like the younger but
the students they're more accepted and
the students are you know referring to
them by the you know like the pronouns
but they want to be referred to by and
stuff like that and I think as best as
they can I mean they're not totally
cognitive at all you know but you know
you don't see much like hate hate or
whatever now I haven't seen it's more
like some sloppiness in terms of just
them not understanding quite well yeah
I've never seen any mother well I like
okay now it's not transgender but are
there any just transvestites I don't
know no no I mean like are there
transvestites at the school are there
any say like for example men boy boys
that dresses women but they don't
identify as as women they as girls they
identify as boys dressed as girls yeah I
don't know I mean I I guess I don't know
like it's more like a stop or are there
any gossip there's goth kids yeah I but
transfer sighs I don't know who's trans
fest have you encountered any kids who
like don't want identify with any gender
who are like oh I'm non-binary that's
the thing I've heard but I'd imagine
it's probably more something that adults
yeah I know that is but like I don't I
don't know any students never encounter
that okay I'm sorry I got this quick
question here there's different you know
how in high school there's different
cliques there's different kind of
there's different scenes you know I mean
kind of or the different subcultures in
high school what are the subcultures of
today are the same classics that we you
know grew up with in the 80s are they
different are they are they different
now they're new kind of clicks now you
know what I mean like jocks got
cheerlead you know whatever stoners you
know all that or is it still the same
yeah it's the same thing they're not are
there any new groups though now I don't
think so yeah cyborgs
I never seen cyborgs yeah we're like you
know just like anime oh yeah yeah no
cyborgs I'm looking forward to cyber
yeah that would be you know be safe
coming soon yeah okay well listen thank
you so much for thank you James being
our guest here today
and telling us about your experience
with them being an English teacher I
appreciate high school yeah thank you
for opening up and answering some
interesting questions and we really
appreciate it was very informative and
thank you to all of you for being here
and being a part of this you know
well let's I guess let's give James a
hand yeah our engineer is Aaron Brent
GART thank you to Andrew Michonne for
being here thank you my name is Brent
Weinbach
the name of the program is pointed
questions thank you for listening